[Music]
well you know it's this whole Khalid
crisis happening another aspect that a
lot of people are talking about is
dating the dating world right now in
this climate is very interesting so a
lot of people are talking about how they
have actually matched a lot more people
but obviously they're not going out into
face-to-face dates so the entire dating
world scene has changed are people just
cyber [ __ ] more you can cyber [ __ ]
pretty much no emoji [ __ ] well it's more
like so there was this have a [ __ ]
there's this one girl that got
interviewed as she was saying how a lot
of people are actually being a lot more
emotionally open because now there's not
that pressure of like oh I'm gonna be
meeting you face to face pretty soon
like there's no like front because now
it's just like oh we're both suck in
each other's homes at least we can
actually get to know each other and you
actually establish a relationship yeah
and actually get to know like the inner
workings of each other's minds yeah
being like it's like in the movies when
like the characters are about to die and
they're like I gotta tell you something
I've never said it to anyone but I
actually love you yeah so true I also
feel like on the flip side there's
probably a ton of couples breaking up
because there's so much [ __ ] cabin
fever they're like [ __ ] I didn't know
how annoying this prison was imaginable
can you imagine going through a divorce
right now and you're in the same house
Oh stock you know I'm doing it
I guess my literally like are we gonna
have a go her husband except for
separation and they're stuck together
now and he's like hey I'll go get
groceries
I think she's gonna dip back but it's
like man that's so [ __ ] up right like
my heart goes out to her so much cuz
it's like like in this time like if you
are if you are if you went into this
alone like that's one thing right but if
you went in there went into this with a
partner somebody that you expect to be
there to lift you up at doing this this
is trying like none of us know what's
gonna happen from this [ __ ] yeah how
long was your last any type of thing and
financially she did have no clues that
he was gonna drop them
and financially from a financial aspect
it's like you just went from one income
to I mean for two incomes to one I need
the one in my like working right now
because he works in clubs and she was
like I forgot what she does but like me
the one that I'm working right now so I
was like wow dude if we had our old
apartment set up I feel like I would get
crazy cabin fever because our old
apartment was like a lot smaller and it
was one story and Steve worked in the
living room and you can hear everything
in that house and so like Steve has been
which is really cool he's been like
Skype screenwriting so him and his
writing partner will be like on skype
but when Steve is in a creative zone
he gets loud as [ __ ] he's like oh my God
he's so loud but our current setup his
office is like all the way downstairs
and on this side yeah and then mine is
like upstairs and all the way over here
you guys are super rich super to
different places and then when I get a
snack in the kitchen I hear him like oh
I'm like oh wow this is great this is a
great setup because if we were in our
old place
I would get so oh you know how that
would always be like man it's me Mario
had to work together we would break up
immediately so I texted him like oh yeah
cuz I'm like David I've been thinking
about you how are you in Muriel he was
like it's cool I mean she's watching her
kdramas and I'm just cooking up just to
cook like cooking things just to cook so
I don't know it's kind of boring and I'm
like yeah cuz I felt like I don't know
are you guys gonna make it to your
wedding cuz you have to be cooped up
together you know what he sent me last
night he was sending me all these
drumline videos and then I'm like their
cannon movie no no like just like actual
drumline like plain linear and [ __ ] he's
like Russian drumline he's like oh I
love with Nick does this
absolutely drumline [ __ ] and I'm like
David you're [ __ ] bored huh he's like
yeah oh yeah we're all bored oh man no
we're not
I've little I've never thought more
about like doing black heroin in my life
until like this last week I was like I
mean they say you can't get off of it up
to the first day but I feel like I could
really be madder can't I get over black
tar heroin not the whole day I was just
like inject halfway black and then I
pull out the other day I went to a
restaurant just so I could be around
people this is before they close it's
true and I was by myself
I went during a a 60 year old woman had
a birthday party at this restaurant
and she had like 25 people all there and
I said at the bar and it was exactly
what I needed just refilled my tank the
brim wait yeah this is perfect for me I
didn't wait for today my tank dude I
just put on low fight hip-hop B's and I
could just watercolor for like eight
hours eight hours watering water
coloring yeah like I put on some like
hip-hop beats and I just water colors
all right Nikki we get it you put also
ever there and put on some water sorry
mama
while playing clean up my problem yeah
so appropriately Nana has this extra
time helped your guys's relationship
more or no baby-making we actually
skipped this this what is it called
ovulation so yeah we skipped a cycle I
was like I don't want to be pregnant and
go into hospitals and ob/gyn thank you
thank you thank you at least until we
know what's gonna happen the walking
dead it's like Rick an old girl got
pregnant during the zombie apocalypse
grab some condoms but never never
thought that that's what staying about
during the Great Depression where people
are all we still survived through that
that means in the darkest times people
are still [ __ ] yeah energy but this is
like you'll use a condom
yeah oh I get all burgers over like in
the walking dead it's like it's not like
I'm pregnant it's like I'm pregnant
yeah [ __ ] how we gonna do this [ __ ] no
cuz um I was also seeing some tweets
that they're like well you know that
there was baby boom now there's gonna be
a new be like a boom yeah probably
I think people nowadays are smarter and
more aware of like what it takes to
raise a child and we're more selfish we
live in a very selfish time where it's
like I wanna do what I want to do I want
to travel I want to do it especially
coming out of a 14 if you come out of a
quarantine the last thing you want to do
is like be a parent like you want to get
out so I think like I think people will
be smarter now plus cost of living is so
high like right now compared to what it
was or like the 1950s or whatever's
right you might not be after this man we
don't know when this is gonna end the
economy this could be a great evening of
many things I hope is the evening of gas
cuz I'm sick of it it seems to me I got
my it hasn't gone down like really much
here well it just happened right so like
the oil oil market just crashed big-time
the other day like I think was like five
days ago or something so it should roll
in I'm waiting I still pay 389 a gallery
traveling to I have to v8 okay but we
are you traveling one car one car gets
30 miles a gallon d'Elegance yeah but
your inner it makes you rich what the
[ __ ] I mean I'm in Glyndon I still be
drivers cylinders I've only have 16 you
say yep yep I'm dropping at the same
time pushing each other like yeah party
everyone is the old school okay right
and there's nothing I do about that and
then in the infinity that was that's
been my favorite course is I'm in high
school okay we got a boat - she just
doesn't let me drive her car I get it
and like sometimes at night I will just
get in my car and I just cruise like
that's soo than especially right now
where there's no traffic like the open
roll it with good music and like a good
sounds like that's beautiful I saw a
motorcycle is this morning and he just
going like this between the lanes
because there's no my god when I told
you I came from Sherman Oaks to Glendale
like this I went at the peak of rush
hour it was and it was so clear I just
drove on the highway looking backwards I
didn't even use a camera there Rises it
reminds me that Carmageddon remember
Carmageddon yeah it was dude they said
for weeks like don't go on the road on
this day at this time you're [ __ ] this
whole weekend and then everyone listened
and everyone listened but I checked it
out because I love check Sam I had an
audition and I was like oh [ __ ] I got on
the 405 during Carmageddon and there was
no one there it was better than right
now yeah it was crazy it was like you
see tumbleweeds roll by yeah legit
though I can never do this
[Laughter]
the Monday case R and s it over I know
this makes me think too about back to
the single thingy how people are like if
no one's meeting face to face but
they're still eager to find love
mmm Oh Mike how's that gonna work it's
like a pen pal thing mm-hmm
yeah but like I guess intimately I don't
know I was a very isolated you mean
[ __ ] yeah okay you eventually meet it
falls like so like a lot I'm not seeing
a lot of people I'd like like FaceTime
[ __ ] I'm thinking like the worst case in
there cuz right now like today just so
you guys know today's March 19th so as
of today there's not like anything
insanely crazy where it's like that's
why we're here we can leave our houses
still but I'm just thinking like further
down the line what if things get even
crazier like like Italy for example
where you literally cannot get out of
your house or else you get arrested like
that insanely crazy and then who knows
how long that'll last like you trying to
arrest me I'm a call phone you like I
got something there's a mandatory stay
inside order in San Francisco and I
think you just in Fresno they're six
counties of the bedroom yeah I just
think like you they can't do it forever
and eventually you're gonna get to me
and maybe I was just because like when I
was throughout childhood like I was
pretty isolated involuntarily but then I
became a you know an M&M Ford moderator
and we were in the voice chat like every
day and I felt like those people were my
best friends and I had never seen them
face to face ever and like I fell in
love with this one guy and like like
that's what you love love is blind
I guess well I don't know if I love love
is my honey no I mean thank you watch it
yeah I could relate I could relate cuz
like yeah I was talking to this guy and
I just fell in love with his voice oh
yeah yeah it was like love is life boys
but but yeah so we would send each other
like we would hand write each other like
cards during Christmas time and stuff
and it was like mail it and
yeah and like and then he went to
problem with a different girl and then I
felt I was like really sad it was my
first heartbreak love is blind as a
[ __ ] wack ass show dude dude love is
blind the show where okay so the first
time you see it happen you see a man get
on one knee and propose to a [ __ ]
wall yeah we and then all of a sudden
you see [ __ ] seven people do it so
you think this guy's nuts oh you guys
[ __ ] nuts just post a wall what a
[ __ ] idiot right and then everyone's
do anything like crying like will you
marry me to a wall well how long do they
get to talk I don't know a couple days
yeah it's not it's nuts man these are
people who are [ __ ] thirsty to get
there with that show was that they had
to get married like if he was just had
to you yeah
we're if it was just dating like do one
thing but yeah they they had to prepare
to pump up the fake story and then they
had to live together how's things will
this dip bread the whole thing is like
on the altar is when you decide if
you're gonna stay together so they have
to they have to have a wedding like what
think he's saying you have to you don't
have to get married per se but you have
to have the theatrics yeah yeah who's
paying for this [ __ ] done okay well
doubt that I'll do but I'm not
[Music]
[Music]